Just like NumPy, many Panda's
functions also take an axis argument.
And you can use axis = 0 or
axis = 1, like for NumPy,
but you can also use axis = index or
axis = columns.
Now this sounds like it should make
it easier to remember which version
of the axis argument is which, but
it can actually be pretty confusing.
Taking the mean with axis equals
columns will actually not
give the mean of each column.
Instead it gives the mean of each row.
The idea is that you are taking
the mean along the columns.
Similarly with axis = index, you
are taking the mean along the index, or
the rows.
I still have trouble remembering which
way the axis argument will work, so
again I always try it out in iPython and
see what happens before
I use the argument.